this is the sauce on top of this
horrific sandwich we're eating
Chick-fil-A guys they're going woke too
but this one is just incredible here
better at together we are better one of
our core values at Chick-fil-A means
when we combine our unique backgrounds
and experiences with a culture of
belonging we can strengthen the quality
of care we deliver Chick-fil-A's
commitment to being better at together
means embedding diversity equity and
inclusion into everything we do is that
not completely insane how many times do
we have to go through this if you sell a
chicken sandwich
if you sell a water glass whatever you
do that should be the only thing you're
focusing on right we really focus we
really talked about this yesterday once
you let diversity equity and inclusion
in you will destroy the product and
congratulations now even Chick-fil-A you
have been infected you you have been
infected and it just who cares how many
people you have making chicken
sandwiches who are black lesbians who
cares how many people you have making
counting your sauce packets and whether
what their sexuality is nobody cares but
congratulations it's now in your system
and it'll take out Chick-fil-A too mark
my words
laughs
[Music]